[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATE STANIFORTH:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks very much for having
me to Google headquarters.
I'm very glad to be here.
Here's my plan for the
next 45 minutes or so.
I'd like to talk to
you about the book.
And I'm happy to
answer any questions
you have at the end of this.
But it occurs to me that if
I'm talking about magic as I
see it, and you're sitting
there thinking of laser beams,
and smoke machines, and
tight leather pants,
and top hats, and
rabbits, and Job
from "Arrested
Development," we're
never going to
understand each other.
So I'd like to start
by just telling you
a little bit of my story.
And at some point in the
middle of that, it will pivot,
and we'll go from there.
So I became a
magician by accident
when I was a nine year old.
I read the "Lord of
the Rings" books.
You've seen the movies
or read the books?
Yeah.
So there's this scene
at the beginning
of the first "Lord
of the Rings" book
where the wizard Gandalf
is at a birthday party,
and he uses magic to shoot these
magical fireworks into the sky.
And it turns into this
dragon, and swoops down,
and terrifies everybody.
And I wanted to be
able to do that.
Because I thought
that if I could
do that on the playground,
I would be unstoppable.
And I very much wanted
to be unstoppable.
So I went-- nine is an unusual
age, because you're old enough
to get through 1,300 pages
of pretty obscure fantasy
literature, and young enough,
at the end of that time,
to still hold out hope
that maybe there's
such a thing as real
magic in the world.
So I finished the "Lord
of the Rings" books,
and I went to the adult
section of the library looking
for a book of spells that I
could do on the playground.
This was my moment.
I was going to
crush it like that.
What I learned instead was that
that's not how magic works.
But I found a book
of sleight of hand,
and I learned my first
really great piece of magic.
And it's very simple.
You put a coin your hand.
When you close your hand and
open it, the coin disappears.
The thing about magic tricks
is that when they are bad,
they are worse than
just about anything,
because it just
looks like a trick.
But when you take a magic
trick and push it far enough
towards excellence, there
is this tipping point
where it no longer looks
like a trick, where
it looks like an actual
supernatural event.
And I became obsessed
with this coin trick.
I bet I put in--
I don't know-- 400 hours
of standing in front
of the bathroom mirror--
I was sort of a
weird little kid--
standing in front
of the bathroom
mirror practicing
this over and over.
For some kids, it's video games.
For other kids, it's football.
For me, it was mastering,
as a nine year old,
this coin vanish.
And my mom-- because I'd
stand in front of the mirror
and practice, and I'd drop the
coin over and over and over.
She went out and got a carpet
sample and put it on the floor
so it wouldn't
make so much noise.
But after months
of this, there was
a point where it didn't
look like a trick
anymore, where I closed my hand
and opened it, and the coin--
it just disappeared.
And I decided that I wanted to
see how people would respond
to that if I did it at school.
The thing that I couldn't
really have known then
that I've learned since, is that
when you watch a magician, when
you buy a ticket to see my show
or you see a magician on TV,
you understand that you
are seeing an illusion.
Magic is fiction.
And it's just part of the
form that the audience knows
that they are being deceived.
That's why everyone shows up--
to see something that
they can't explain.
When you don't
have that context,
magic isn't entertaining.
It's just terrifying.
If I were to just stand here
in front of you right now
and disappear, the
appropriate response to that
would not be to clap.
It would be like, get up and
run as quickly as you can
from this room.
So the kids watching
on the playground
didn't know that they
were seeing a magic trick.
They didn't know that
I was a magician.
Because I wasn't a magician.
I was just a kid who
had mastered this trick.
So they saw the coin disappear,
and they didn't clap.
They didn't laugh.
They didn't applaud.
They just started
shrieking and running away.
So imagine for a
second that you're
the teacher on duty
at the schoolyard,
and you look across
the playground,
and you see this group of
children screaming and running.
And I'm standing in the middle.
So this teacher stormed
across the playground.
And I was terrified
of this woman.
And she towered
above me and demanded
that I show her whatever
it was that I showed
the kids to make them run away.
And so I took the coin
out, and put it in my hand,
and did my little
dance of the fingers.
And when I opened it, it was
like she was a little kid.
I had never seen
any adult anywhere
respond to anything the
way this grown, educated,
terrifying woman was
reacting to this coin vanish.
And I suppose
that's a fun story.
But for me, it was
very troubling.
Because I knew it
was just a trick.
I knew that I was
just a little kid who
had learned a coin trick.
And I could not
explain the disparity
between the very simple means
and the staggeringly unexpected
result that came from something
as simple as a coin trick.
So I didn't become
a magician because I
wanted to be a performer.
I didn't become a
magician because I
wanted to be in entertainment
or get on stage.
It's like I discovered,
at a really young age,
that you can say something
with a magic trick that's
hard to say any other way.
And I just wanted to chase
that as far as I could.
I think it's one thing as a
nine year old to say that you're
going to become the
greatest magician
in the history of the world.
It's another thing to say
that as a 19 year old.
And I went to college
on an acting scholarship
because I wanted
to study stagecraft
because I thought it would
lead me to become a better
performer.
But what I learned instead
was that the best way
to learn magic is to
just do it for people,
to do it for anyone you can find
in all different walks of life.
And the discovery
that I made is that it
doesn't matter who you are.
You can be young,
old, rich, poor.
You can be a
sheepherder in Tibet
or a taxi driver in Texas.
It doesn't matter.
Everyone everywhere
in the world responds
to a good piece of magic
in exactly the same way.
It's like this
universal experience.
The question that
I've been chasing
as a magician for as long as
I can remember is very simple.
I've noticed that
as I get older,
it becomes harder for me to be
genuinely amazed by anything.
To be clear, it's easy
to be entertained.
It's easy to be inspired.
It's also easy to be
deceived or fooled.
All of the experiences that
are in orbit around wonder
are relatively common.
But for me, that white
light through the clouds--
astonishment-- does
get harder and harder
to find as I get older.
I think one of
the reasons I love
magic so much is it's a
way for me to chase that.
But even as a young magician--
I feel like in every
profession, you probably
get to see a corner of the
human experience that's harder
to see from another profession.
Doctors probably see
things in waiting rooms
that you don't
see anywhere else.
I don't know what
architects learn
about being a human
being, but I'm
sure there's something there.
But for magicians, especially
as a young magician,
it becomes impossible
to ignore the loss that
happens in the
transition from being
a child to being a grown-up.
Because you see in all of--
as a kid, I remember
doing magic for my parents
and the friends of my parents.
And it became clear that there
is this incredible weight that
settles on people when you're an
adult. And with a magic trick,
you can make that go
away for a second.
I love that.
I think the obvious
answer to why
is it harder to become
amazed by anything
as you get older than
it is when you're
a kid is that when you're an
adult, you just know more.
You have more information.
But that answer falls apart
for me for a few reasons.
I think the magician operates
from the fundamental conviction
that learning more
about anything
makes that thing more amazing
rather than less amazing.
It's the absolute
renunciation of the axiom that
familiarity breeds contempt.
Just before I got married, I
was reading this book about--
I was fascinated by lightning.
I just wanted to
understand what it was.
And so I was reading
this meteorological book.
And then my wife and I
happened to be on our honeymoon
in the middle of the
Canadian wilderness.
We went on this
wilderness canoe trip.
And we got pinned down
on an island seven days
from the middle of nowhere
with this lightning
storm that came in.
And it was one of the most
terrifying moments in my life,
because lightning was slamming
over and over and over
onto the trees on our island.
You could hear
trees falling, and I
was worried that a tree was
going to fall on our tent.
And it was terrifying.
But it was also,
if I'm honest, one
of the most riveting, wonderful,
wide awake moments of my life.
And I reckon it was in one
scene, in one experience,
the reality of lightning--
I understood that understanding
the nature of lightning,
understanding that it's a static
discharge from the clouds that
explodes to the ground in
this cataclysmic blast--
knowing the facts
about lightning
does nothing to remove
the astonishment
of being in the middle
of a thunderstorm.
So I love magic for
a number of reasons.
But one of them is that it's a
way to connect with the unknown
and to make peace
with the fact that I
don't have all the answers.
I will never have
all the answers.
And to share that
experience with an audience.
A few years ago,
I decided that I
wanted to write a book
about all of this--
about wonder, about
disillusionment,
about losing sight
of astonishment,
and all of the things
that I love about magic
and finding it again.
And when I finished
writing the book,
I was worried that it's easy to
get up and talk about wonder.
It's easy to write
a book about wonder
when you're sitting
in a Starbucks
paying $5 for a cup of coffee.
But I wanted to see if
it would still hold up
if I went to the toughest,
most aggressive, most hostile
place I could find.
So I asked a warden of a
maximum security prison
if I could come in to do
magic for the inmates.
And it was one of the
most incredible events
of my entire career.
I'd like to show you
the video, but here's
what I want you to see.
Before the magic happens, they
wanted nothing to do with it.
They wanted nothing
to do with it.
They were standing like this,
sort of tough and antagonistic.
And then you will see there is
a moment where something happens
that they can't explain.
And it's just like
a switch flips.
And you will see these--
some of these guys are
in prison for life,
and you will see them--
I don't know-- become
little kids again.
So if I can get this video to
work, I'd like to show you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm going to use
a deck of cards.
I'm going to give it to
you to hold for the moment.
We're going to need--
here, will you name a card?
- Eight of diamonds.
- OK, eight of diamonds.
Will you name a number?
- 13.
We have eight of diamonds, 13.
And you were holding the card.
I want you to see this.
I'm going to give you the deck.
Before we start, I want to just
point out a couple of things.
You could have named any card.
You agree there is no
way I could have made
you think of eight of diamonds.
Is that right?
- Right.
- You don't want to
change your mind.
Eight of diamonds.
Same with the number.
That was your choice.
You said-- what was it?
- 13.
Right.
OK.
And you've been
holding the cards.
With that hand, I want you
to just deal the cards.
Just drop them on the ground.
Let's see.
You said 13.
So deal 12 cards from the
top, and just drop them
on the ground.
Go.
Count them out loud.
- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
- There you go.
Stop.
Drop that one on the ground.
Can we all agree the next
card is the 13th card, right?
- Right.
- So you could have
picked any card,
but you said eight of diamonds.
You could have picked any
number, but you said 13.
If you had said a
different number,
we'd go farther down in
the deck or stop higher.
You said 13, eight of diamonds.
Turn over the 13th.
[LAUGHTER]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Can you see that
wherever you're standing?
I'm going to hold it so
the camera can get it.
I want you to see
it's permanent.
So here's the idea.
Watch this.
Look at your hand here.
- Damn!
That's crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
- Now throw it back.
- No, it's permanent.
It's going to stay there.
- Throw it back.
- Take if off and
give it back to him.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- That's great.
- You can see the thread, right?
You can see it on camera too.
Listen.
More than anything, I
want you to hear this.
I'll give that to
you for a second.
Thank you.
Listen.
I want you to hear it.
Can you hear it break?
I'm going to do it again.
So here's the idea.
I'm going to take some
of the broken pieces.
And I don't want you
to think I'm adding
anything or switching anything.
These are the pieces
I'm going to use.
I'm going to roll
them up into a ball.
You can see all the broken ends
get pulled together, right?
This is the amazing part.
If you take the ball of
broken pieces and squeeze,
the idea is to get
it to just stick.
Will you help me?
Just grab the bottom.
Do this slowly so the
ball doesn't fall off
as you start to pull.
[LAUGHTER]
- OK.
- That was bad, man.
[END PLAYBACK]
NATE STANIFORTH: So
when I finished college,
I started touring as a
professional magician.
And for me, that looked
like essentially living out
of a suitcase and bouncing
around the country
doing a show as often
as I could five nights
a weeks, six nights a week.
I think when you're an
established magician,
you can tour in a circuit,
sort of like a band.
So you can play
Denver one night,
and Fort Collins the next night,
and maybe Colorado Springs,
and work your way across.
Maybe go to Lincoln,
and then Des Moines,
and tour across the country.
But when you're
just starting out,
you have to go
wherever the work is.
And so I do Tuesday in Florida,
Wednesday in California,
Thursday in Ohio, just
criss-crossing the country.
And I did that for five years.
And I discovered that
maybe like most jobs,
the profession of
magic, which I thought
looked so amazing
from the outside,
concealed beneath that
veneer this grinding,
day-to-day reality.
My commute would be 15 hours.
I'd wake up at 3:00 in the
morning to get to the show,
and then do sound check and
load in, and do the show,
and then go to bed and
sleep for four hours,
and then get up and
do that all again
the next night, and the next
night, and the next night.
And after five years,
I just ran into a wall.
I just felt like I
couldn't do it anymore.
I was onstage in
Milwaukee in front
of-- it was a beautiful
auditorium, a great audience,
and the show was going well.
And in the middle of the
show, I just said, I'm sorry.
I'm done.
I hope you had a good time,
but I'm going to go now.
I walked off in the
middle of the set
and went back to my
hotel room and thought,
maybe this ship is sinking.
Maybe I'm not going to do
this anymore, because I do not
want to have this be what my--
I don't want my life to
look like this anymore.
The universe, I think, is a
strange and mysterious place.
And once in a while,
incredible things just happen.
And it just so happened that
on this leg of the tour,
I happened to be
reading this book
about traditional
Indian street magic.
Every culture in the
world has its own version
of the archetypal
figure of the magician.
Just like food or art
or music, the magic
that comes from a
culture is as much
an expression of that culture
as any of the other arts.
So had I been reading a book
about Chinese traditional
magic, I would have
wanted to go to China,
or Japanese magic, maybe I would
have wanted to go to Japan.
But after I walked off
in the middle of the set
and went back to my hotel
room, I picked up this book
and started reading it.
And I decided that
what I wanted to do
was walk away from
everything in the US,
to just leave my touring career
behind and forget everything
I knew about being a
magician in America,
and go to the other side of the
world to see all of this magic
I was reading about.
So I wanted to see
snake charming.
I wanted to see
street performing.
I wanted to see fire breathing.
It wasn't so much that I wanted
to go to India specifically.
I just wanted to
go to this place
where all of these things I was
reading about were performed.
So my mission was I wanted
to go be amazed by something.
I wanted to remember why I
loved being a magician so much
by seeing a tradition
of magic that's
totally different from my own.
And so I did.
I went to India, and I sought
out snake charmers and street
performers.
I found a tribe of traditional
Indian street magicians who
trace their lineage and have
passed their secrets down
from father to son
for 3,000 years.
I saw amazing magic, so I found
what I was looking for there.
But what I discovered was
that the most amazing parts
of the trip, the most
genuinely magical moments that
felt like I think magic should
feel, good magic should feel,
had nothing to do with
tricks and nothing
to do with performances.
It was in immersing
myself in a new culture,
seeing things I had
never seen before.
Both travel and magic are
similar in their ability
to deliver this
cataclysmic death
blow to any sense of certainty
you have about who you are
and how you fit in with
the world around you.
And so I became
really fascinated
with this idea of finding
wonder not in the extraordinary,
but in the ordinary.
It's one thing to find it on
the other side of the world
or find it in a magic show,
but how do you find it
in your day-to-day life?
How do you-- adults are really
good at making things ordinary.
We're really good at
getting used to things,
which is probably useful.
If we woke up every
morning and freaked out
at this bright, burning
ball of thermonuclear fury
rising over the east, that would
be an untenable way to live.
We should just call it the
sun and get on with our day.
But the danger is
that you end up
shrinking your world down to
the size of your certainties.
And you live in the
story you tell yourself
about the world rather
than the world itself.
And my favorite
moments are those
that wake me up, and shake
me loose from that world
that I've made for
myself, and remind me
that there's more that I'm
not paying attention to.
When I came back
from India, I was
worried that that was a
lot to ask of a magic show.
For the first
time, I felt like I
had something I wanted
to say that I didn't
know how to say as a magician.
So I started learning
to write, and I decided
I was going to write a book.
And that's the book that
all of you are holding,
"Here is Real Magic."
When the book came out, I wanted
to invent a piece of magic that
would set the stage to tell
everyone what to expect
from a book by a magician.
And I'd like to show it to you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
NATE STANIFORTH: My book
came out in January,
and so I've been doing a
number of these author talks.
And sometimes when I open
the room up for questions,
everybody has something
they want to say.
And sometimes no
one has anything
they want to talk about.
But I would like to open
the room up for questions.
We can talk about magic.
We can talk about the book.
We can talk about wonder
or the ideas in the book.
We can arm wrestle,
whatever you want.
But if you have anything that
you'd like to talk about,
now is the time.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I have unsolicited
feedback and comments, and then
a question.
NATE STANIFORTH: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So I
watched you watching
that video, which I'm sure
you've seen about 100 times.
And you are the one
doing the tricks.
And so you weren't
smiling at the tricks.
You were smiling
at the reactions.
I could tell that's very--
it's just awesome.
I believe you when you
were telling that story
of impacting the people.
I've always loved magic
and hated magicians.
So I think--
NATE STANIFORTH: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But then wondered, all
right, why is it real for you
and maybe not for
a larger handful--
NATE STANIFORTH: Of
magicians specifically?
I don't want to speak to--
it's hard to comment on what
other people's motives might
be, so I don't want
to assume anything
about other magicians
that might not be true.
But I think you probably
have the same thing
in music as well.
Some people get into
music because they
want to be rock stars, and they
want to have everybody scream
and go crazy, and they
want to be famous.
And then you have people
who get into music
because they love music,
and they love writing songs.
And I'm not saying one
is better than another.
But for me, being
a performer is--
it's something-- I've made
my peace with it, for sure,
but that's not why
I got into magic.
I got into it because
I love the thing that I
am able to chase as a magician.
And if I could do it better
as a musician, maybe I would.
Magic has a lot of
cultural baggage to it.
But I just-- personally, I
love the experience of magic.
You don't need to do
tricks to do magic.
The first time I really
remember the experience
of being amazed by
something was when
my parents took
me to see a meteor
shower when I was a little kid.
And we lived in a small college
town in the middle of Iowa.
But even in a
small college town,
there's enough light
pollution that makes
it hard to see the Milky Way.
But they woke me up in
the middle of the night
and drove my brother
and sister out
into the cornfields
where there's no light.
And it just--
I remember feeling like, where
has this been all my life?
It was one of the most
amazing things, still,
that I've ever seen.
And I love that experience.
And I'll follow that anywhere.
And if that means,
as part of the job,
getting up and doing a
magic show, that's fine.
But I guess that's
my way of answering
how I feel about it, trying
not to speak for other people.
Is that fair?
AUDIENCE: That's fair.
NATE STANIFORTH: OK.
Thank you for asking.
Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that when we see a magic show,
we know it's an illusion.
And part of the fun is
trying to see how it's done.
[INAUDIBLE],, you know
it could be failing.
When you go to see a
magic show, obviously, it
must be quite a
different experience,
because you have a
pretty good idea how
a lot of the common
effects are done.
That must change the experience
for you quite a lot to one
of being amazed to one of
trying to see how it's done.
How often do you find yourself
astonished and amazed by magic?
NATE STANIFORTH: So I'd like
to answer that in two parts.
So the experience I'm having
now, having written this book,
is now that I have been
through the process
of writing a book myself--
and it took four years
of pretty rigorous work.
When I read other
people's work, I
feel like sometimes I can
see the joints and the beams
and the girders in a way
that I couldn't before.
And it has changed the way
I read certainly memoirs,
too, because now I have this
professional relationship
with that form that necessarily
changes the way I take it in.
That's been true for
magic for a long time.
And as you say, it's hard
not to watch a magic show
and deconstruct it.
But I would say that
like the best writers,
you read some books,
and there are no seams.
It's just like it arrived fully
formed from some other world.
A great magic show
is that way too.
And in the book, I
describe one piece of magic
that I witnessed that--
I saw it in 2013, and
I've thought about it,
without exaggeration,
every day since 2013.
And I still can't explain it.
And I love that.
I love the realization
that no matter how far
I push this craft,
there are still people
who are so far ahead of me.
Rather than being
intimidated by that,
I really love that,
because it means
that I can still find that
spark of inspiration as well.
Is that a fair answer?
Yeah.
OK.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So given everything
that you've been through,
and going through the process of
writing the book, what's next?
NATE STANIFORTH:
That's a good question.
Yeah.
I discovered that I
really love book writing.
I feel like I snuck into
this incredible party,
and I very much don't
want to leave now.
So I've got other books
that I'd like to write.
And in the course of writing the
book, there was a lot of work
as a magician that
I didn't do that I'm
catching up on as well.
So I'm trying to
have it both ways
and have this career where I
can go on tour twice a year
and write books.
And we'll see if I
can stick the landing.
But that's very much the goal.
So thanks for asking.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What advice would you
give today to that 9,
10-year-old boy or
girl getting into magic
and wants to do magic?
NATE STANIFORTH: There's
this quote from Houdini
that I discovered when
I was a little kid.
You're all familiar
with Houdini?
Yeah.
So Houdini said--
Houdini was like the
original Gary Vaynerchuk.
He said, the real secret
to my success is simple.
I work from 7:00 AM to
midnight, and I like it.
And I think one of the reasons
I latched on to magic is
because I just really liked that
monk-like existence of having
one--
my life was very simple.
I had one job, and it
was to perfect this craft
to the exclusion of
basically anything else.
And I think whether you're
interested in magic or music
or poetry or
basket-weaving or whatever,
I think there's a lot to be
said for just working harder
than the other people who are
trying to do the same thing.
Because that's the one
thing you can control.
There are other people who are
more gifted performers or more
charismatic communicators.
But the one point where I
get to choose how I react
is just working harder
than everybody else.
And I don't know.
I think it doesn't suit
everybody, but it suits me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think you were
talking about lightening when
you brought this
up, but you talked
about how as you
learned more about it,
it increased the amount
of wonder and awe in it.
Does that apply
with magic tricks?
NATE STANIFORTH:
Certainly, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Even when
you learn more about
how the trick is done,
you're more inspired by it?
NATE STANIFORTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain that?
That seems counter-intuitive.
NATE STANIFORTH: Absolutely.
I think one of the things
that you discover as you--
I'm going to say explore
the craft of magic--
I assume this is true
with music, or with art,
with painting, or poetry,
or writing, or whatever.
But the better you get,
the larger your awareness
of how far you have to go.
The distance between good and
great becomes much clearer.
When I was starting
out, it was harder
to understand
exactly what it would
take to take an illusion all the
way to the point of perfection.
And I think the closer
you get to that,
the easier it is to see
how almost impossible
it is to become as good as
some of the greats have been.
Magic is interesting.
I think of magic like fiction.
It's easy to think that--
with a magic trick,
it's easy to assume
that once you know the answer,
you can stop thinking about it.
But I think a good
piece of magic,
like a good
fictional character--
you don't finish
"Catcher in the Rye"
and then say, well,
that was a good story,
but Holden Caulfield wasn't a
real kid, so who cares anymore?
A good novelist is using
the craft of deception.
Let's be clear about that.
He's making, or she's making
things up that aren't true
and pulling you into
this imaginary world
to give you something real.
And in my experience,
the better I
get as a magician,
the more I become
aware of the complexities
that are involved
in actually doing that well.
Does that begin to--
is that a fair answer?
Does that-- yeah.
OK.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I've got a son
who's stumbled into magic
and is really into it.
NATE STANIFORTH: I'd
watch out for that.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes it's to
the exclusion of other things,
like homework.
But he's gotten to the
point where he's starting
to get really good at it.
He can go to parties with
adults and do a card trick,
and the adults are stumped.
And the same reaction
that you're looking for
is the reaction
that he's getting.
And he's falling
in love with it.
So my question for you is
how many times did people
tell you--
your mom grabbed the
carpet out and put it
on the floor for you.
How many times did
people discourage you,
and how did you
get over the hump?
NATE STANIFORTH: All the time.
I mean, basically everyone, I
think for the best of reasons.
It seems to be the
prudent thing to do
to discourage
someone from becoming
a professional magician.
Of course.
It's not-- joining the circus,
it's becoming the circus.
But I think sometimes, you
know something about yourself
that you can't
prove to the people
in your life in any other
way but by doing it.
There were a number of years,
especially when I was first
working as a professional
magician, where I think
basically, everyone
who cared about me
was terrified that I would
be unemployed in two years.
And they were probably
right to be concerned.
But I knew that I was doing
what I was supposed to be doing.
And it's like I didn't even
care what they thought.
I just knew that I could
do it, and then show them,
and then that would be enough.
I think that anyone who makes
it in a profession like magic
only--
I think the only people
that make it don't
care what anyone else says.
After shows, sometimes
young magicians
come up to me asking if they
should make the jump to being
a professional.
And I never know
how to answer that,
because the only ones
who will ever make it
are the ones who are so
committed to doing it
that they don't care
what I have to say.
And I don't know what
advice to give you,
because it almost seems like--
it's such a hard way
to make a living,
and it's such a hard
field to gain traction
in that unless that motivation,
that fire comes from within,
it's not going to happen.
So maybe discouraging him
is the right thing to do.
I don't know.
I think you can
split the difference.
I think you can be realistic
and supportive at the same time.
And if you figure that
out, you let me know.
I have a five year old
and a three year old.
But good luck either way.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
NATE STANIFORTH: Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you've been doing
it for a really long time.
Do you have any stories
of the craziest reactions
that you've gotten?
Or has anyone gotten aggressive
after you fooled them
with a trick, or
anything [INAUDIBLE]??
NATE STANIFORTH: I was
onstage in Danville, Virginia.
And I had just done a piece
of magic with someone onstage,
and he felt as if I
had read his mind.
And he was conflicted
about that.
There was tension in the room.
It wasn't like, oh,
this is amazing.
We're having fun.
It was like, burn this guy.
And he went back to
his seat and just sat
there festering for 90 seconds.
And then he stood up on his
chair-- and this was a theater,
so there were armrests.
And he climbed up on the
armrests to get my attention,
which worked.
And pointed at me and
said, to hell with you.
You're the devil.
I'm out of here.
And stormed out of the room.
The highlight of my career.
So I'm just putting
that out there.
But yeah, I think like we were
talking about at the beginning,
when magic feels like a trick--
and let's be clear.
Most magic does
feel like a trick.
You can take the same piece of
magic and perform it 100 times,
and 99 of those times,
it will only ever
feel like a competently done
piece of sleight of hand.
But through some
mysterious combination
of atmosphere and expectation
and technical ability and just
coincidence, sometimes
the air is just right,
and it resonates on a
totally different level.
And then people go crazy.
And yeah, I feel
like magicians get
to see a very beautiful
side of people.
Because I think we all are
performing for each other
all the time.
We all choose the clothes
we wear and the language,
the vocabulary that we use.
We're all putting off an
image of ourselves the way
we want to be
received or perceived.
And a great thing about
magic, when it's really good,
is it makes you forget
to be cool for a second.
And all of that falls away.
And you just get this very
open, unguarded experience
of the personalities
that you're with.
And often, that's a
positive experience.
But yeah, sometimes people
just lose their cool.
Thanks for bringing it up.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]